cheers baby here to St Bart the OG
[__] are back I'm wondering if
there's going to be some cute guys there
oh there's always somebody to we need a
new
[Music]
pirate all right St pirat hello we made
it we made it hi I just got here fresh
from New York we're going back to the
same Villa is it bringing back memories
staring and we don't want to eat without
you it's 4:00 didn't you miss her you
have a boyfriend you have no boyfriend I
have whatever I want and I'm very
pleased can you tell us who it is I'm so
normal and even tempered Kelly is like
dealing with one of those Rubik cues I
am an action verb you're an action verb
okay you've been ask me all day long get
a mat not a houseand on fire names will
never hurt me there's six women here and
you're all divorced Kristen's husband
was cheating he admitted to being a
member of the Affairs website is it a
flirting thing
I know my truth Eagles don't fly with
pigeons okay so go get your breadcrumbs
and get back to me tomorrow I'm trying
with you I'm so trying with you I know
but you're not the right the right I
need nurturing from
darinda is that a turtle look it Turtle
time baby
[Music]
[Applause]
turtle you think I already
oh God snatch you found out that Sonia
has a pretty kitty who in the bre we
have 10 guys showing up 10
guys it's certainly not the first Hot
Dog I've seen on this trip but it's the
first one I'm going to get out and
ride I'm on it I don't know what an
Eddie monster shoe looks
like the pirate has tried to call me
9,000
times I am your pirate that the pirate
are you forny as I am we need to get on
a spiritual Retreat after this first
maybe I will go to um mental house dis
mental hospital yeah kudos to that we
can say Kos to
that I love a powerful shower
[Music]
head